for more information on tutoring
personalized video solutions or how to
support move university and the
production of more videos check out move
University calm thank you and enjoy so
in this video series we're going to be
talking about compounds and the basics
of bonding and the reason why we need to
talk about this topic is because most
elements that exist in nature exists in
nature chemically combined with other
elements in substances that are called
compounds okay very few elements exist
as free separate atoms most of them like
I said are in compounds so it makes
sense that with the study compounds and
bonding and how I'll compounds form some
examples of free separate atoms include
the noble gases right the noble gases
are super stable and they don't really
form compounds they are of course helium
neon argon Krypton xenon and radon and
they are group 8a on the periodic table
right there right in light blue okay
also there are some metals that exist as
free separate atoms there are a handful
of elements that exist at exist diatomic
Lee I don't even know if that's a word I
atomically but there are seven diatomic
elements die referring to two atomic
referring to atoms so basically the
diatomic elements what happens is that
their elemental form the form that they
exist in naturally is a combination of
two atoms and you should commit these
seven to memory they are h2 n 2 o 2 F 2
CL 2 BR 2 and I to okay and the way I
remember it is hydrogen plus a little L
shape right here so n 0 f co BR i right
so that kind of looks like a seven right
there right so these here 1 2 3 4 5 6
plus hydrogen over here those are the
seven diatomic elements so hydrogen does
not exist naturally as just a single
h-atom it exists as h2 okay so same
thing for for oxygen oxygen gas is o2
not just oh okay so when it comes to
forming compounds that we're talking
about a lot in our studies of chemistry
when we think about the subatomic
particles that are important in forming
these compounds electrons are what we
care about most because electrons are
involved in actual bonding and formation
of these compounds and there are two
types of compounds okay ionic compounds
and covalent compounds and they differ
as far as their definitions when it
comes to electrons ionic compounds form
when atoms of one element transfer
electrons to atoms of another element to
form ionic bonds covalent compounds form
when electrons are shared between atoms
of different elements forming covalent
bonds okay so if I think about it like a
tug-of-war with ionic compounds it's
very clear who wins the tug of war one
element entirely takes electrons from
another or you can think about it as one
one element what elements Adam gives its
electrons entirely to another so you can
imagine this being like a tug-of-war
between two people pulling on a rope and
one just totally Yanks the rope from the
other okay whereas covalent compounds
it's not quite the same right there but
both both atoms are pulling on the
electrons right pulling on the rope and
then not are they're not necessarily
pulling with equal strength but the idea
is that neither one entirely takes the
rope from the other neither takes the
electrons entirely from the other the
electrons kind of our existing
between the two okay now each type of
these compounds is held together by what
we call generally speaking chemical
bonds right those two cup two types of
chemical bonds that we just mentioned
are ionic bonds and covalent bonds and
these are the forces that hold the atoms
in the compound together okay I hope
that video is helpful thank you for
watching if you found that video helpful
don't forget to Like comment subscribe
and share with friends thank you and
happy studying